Welcome, everybody.
Good evening.
Hi.
I'm Claire Masood, and I
have the joy and privilege
this evening to welcome
Jenny Erpenbech to Harvard.
For many of us who have read
and admired her work for years,
to have her with us in person
is a particular delight.
I want to thank Jenny for making
the long journey of course, not
least when she's been
battling the flu.
So yes, so we may all be--
I've heard Jenny's
cough, and it's for real.
So we all just have to
beam soothing thoughts
to Jenny's throat I guess.
And I also want to say a
special thanks to [INAUDIBLE]
of Brookline Booksmith--
are you here?
Hi-- Without whom this evening
would not have come to pass.
And to let you know that
Jenny will be reading there
in Brookline tomorrow evening.
I also want to thank Jenny's
publishers, New Directions.
Her editor Declan Spring
has come all the way
from New York this evening.
In addition, I'd like to
thank the team at the Harvard
bookstore who, as always, are
great supporters of the writers
speak series.
While we don't have books
for sale at the event here,
Jenny will be signing
copies tomorrow morning
at the bookstore.
And they're available
unsigned right now.
They'll be available
signed tomorrow
after 11 at the bookshop
just right around the corner.
And as ever, many thanks
to Professor Homi Bhabha
and the Mahindra
Humanities Center,
as well as to Sarah Razor
who makes everything happen.
And of course, thanks
to you all for coming.
Without you we wouldn't be here.
Jenny Erpenbech is a
writer who wastes no words.
From the publication
of her first book,
The Old Child and Other
Stories almost 20 years ago,
she has been recognized
and acclaimed in her native
Germany, dubbed by the
news magazine Der Spiegel,
one of Günter Grass'
grandchildren and photographed
alongside several other writers
with her head on an actual tin
drum.
International
recognition ensued.
The Old Child was published
in the states in 2005.
I think that's right.
Is that right?
Followed by her novels
The Book of Words,
2007 Visitation, 2010
End of Days 2014,
and most recently Go Went
Gone published last year.
She is routinely a
best seller in Germany,
and Go Went Gone
was no exception.
She's been the recipient of too
many prestigious prizes for me
to name.
So here are just the ones
from the past four years--
the Hans Fallada Prize, the
Independent Foreign Fiction
Prize, shared with her
longtime longtime translator
Susan Bernofsky, the Thomas
Mann prize, the [INAUDIBLE]
European prize, and the
Order of Merit of the Federal
Republic of Germany.
As my former
teacher at Cambridge
might have said with a
sardonically raised eyebrow,
will that do?
When you read Jenny's
work, several things
are swiftly apparent.
She is stylistically original,
her prose fiercely vivid,
but also taut, even spare.
She is frequently
formerly inventive,
and her texts, richly conceived,
operate on multiple levels.
Two of her books are carefully
constructed around conceits--
in Visitation, the history of a
lake house, and in End of Days,
the various possible
trajectories of a woman's
life through the 20th century.
Whatever she chooses
to write about,
Jenny addresses only the
most urgent subjects,
whether in the
present, as in Go When
Gone, which involves the
relationship that develops
between a retired
classics professor
named Richard and a
group of African refugees
seeking asylum in Germany,
or in recent history,
as in Visitation or End
of Days, both of which
trace individual histories
through the tumultuous darkness
of Germany's 20th
century, from the fall
of the Austro-Hungarian
empire and the First World
War through interwar privations
to the rise of Hitler
and the Holocaust and then
on to the wrenching division
of Germany and the
bitterness of the Cold War
that march to Jenny's
own childhood.
She was born in 1967.
Her books are eventful and
dramatic, but never histrionic.
They have about them
the adamantine precision
of authenticity, lived or very
carefully researched truth
as assessed by a
penetrating intellect.
Indeed, there is a
neutrality and almost godlike
detachment about
her narration that
makes the most intolerable
scenes both utterly immediate
and only the more
agonizing as when
she writes the murder of a
young Jewish girl in Visitation.
And I quote, "for three years,
the girl took piano lessons.
But now, while her dead body
slides down into the pit,
the word piano is taken
back from human beings.
Now the backflip on
the high bar the girl
could perform better
than her schoolmates is
taken back along with all
the motions a swimmer makes.
The gesture of
seizing hold of a crab
is taken back, as well
as all the basic knots
to be learned for sailing.
All these things are taken
back into uninventivedness.
And finally, last of
all, the name of the girl
herself is taken back, the name
no one will ever again call her
by, Doris."
As Flaubert would have
had it, Jenny Erpenbech
is in her work the way God
is in nature, everywhere but
invisible.
She has drawn on her
family's histories
for inspiration on
numerous occasions,
but her work is far
from autobiographical.
She takes her East German
legacy as neither a cudgel
nor a plaint, but instead
as a frame of reference
that better enables her to
understand the wider world.
She has said, I do believe
that East German authors have
an experiential
advantage from having
lived through a period
of such radical change.
I grew up constantly being
reminded that I lived
on the poorer side of Germany.
Then the whole thing
gets turned upside down,
and you suddenly belong
to the wealthier side.
But you can't forget.
You can't forget what
it felt like to be
on the other side of history.
It allows you to
relate differently
to other people, especially
those for whom things haven't
always fallen into their laps.
Jenny's East German
legacy has never
been more relevant
than it is today.
And we, in this current United
States, should take notice.
People don't tend to believe
me, she said in an interview
already several years ago, but
our default mode in the east
was skepticism towards
the government,
especially among those who still
believe that socialism deserved
a better chance.
When we read a newspaper,
the first question
was always, what does
that really mean.
It gave us a much
better training
and alertness to
potential manipulation.
Sometimes I think that
people in the West
were much more streamlined,
much more easily
manipulated with their
100% faith in democracy
while remaining
largely unquestioning
of the economic system.
We will, I hope, discuss
such broader questions
afterwards among other things.
But let us never lose
sight of the fact
that Jenny's
brilliance is to create
vital, enduring art
rather than news
out of what matters most now.
As she has said with
regard to Go Went Gone,
we are living side
by side with stories
like I grew up with, stories
out of the deep experience
of trying to survive.
In the stories I
grew up with, it
was Jews trying to
survive the fascists.
But now too we are living with
stories that will make history.
These are in our own
city in a parallel world
just under the surface.
And again, people are
simply trying to survive.
Please join me in
welcoming Jenny Erpenbech.
[APPLAUSE]
Is this OK?
This is my water?
This one is yours?
So it's a great honor
for me to be here,
to be introduced
by Claire Masood.
And first, there
will be a reading.
I'm going to start with the
beginning of the book, just
the first 2 and 1/2 pages.
And then I read a bit of
some part about a refugee.
Perhaps many more
years still lie
before him or
perhaps only a few.
In any case, from
now on, Richard
will no longer have
to get up early
to appear at the institute.
As of today, he has
time, plain and simple,
time to travel people say, to
read books, Proust, Dostoevsky,
time to listen to music.
He doesn't know how
long it will take them
to get used to having time.
In any case, his head still
works just the same as before.
What's he going to do with the
thoughts still thinking away
inside his head?
He's had his share of success.
And now at least what
passes for success.
He has published books and
been invited to conferences,
his lectures always filled up.
Students were assigned his books
to read, highlighting passages
to learn by heart
for their exams.
Where are his students now?
Some have a junior
faculty positions,
two or three are even tenured.
Others, he hasn't
heard about in years.
There's one he's
too friendly with,
and a few others drop
him a line periodically.
That's how it is.
From his desk, he sees the lake.
Richard makes coffee.
Cup in hand, he goes
out to the backyard
to check for a new mole hills.
The lake lies placid before
him as it has all summer long.
Richard's waiting but he
doesn't know for what.
Time is now completely
different, suddenly different,
he thinks.
And then he thinks
that obviously he
can't stop thinking.
The thinking is what he is.
And at the same time, it's
the machine that governs him.
Even if he's all alone
with his head now,
he can just stop
thinking obviously,
even if no one gives
a hoot what he thinks.
For a brief moment he
imagines an owl using its beak
to flip the pages of his
study, the concept of the word
and work of Lucretius.
He goes back in.
He asks himself whether it's
too warm to be wearing a Blazer.
Does he even need a Blazer
or if he's just puttering
around the house alone?
Years ago, when he
learned by chance
that his lover was
cheating on him,
the only thing that helped him
get over his disappointment
was turning this
disappointment into work.
For months, he made her
behavior his object of inquiry.
He wrote almost 100
pages investigating
all the factors that
led up to the betrayal,
as well as the way in which the
young woman had carried it out.
His work had no particular
impact on their relationship
as she left him for
good not long after.
But still, these labors got
him through the first months
after his discovery,
months in which he'd
felt truly miserable.
The best cure for love is,
as Ovid knew centuries ago,
is work.
But now he's being
tormented, not
by time filled with pointless
love, but by time itself.
Time is supposed to
pass, but not just dead.
For an instant, he has a vision
of a furious owl tearing apart
a book entitled On Waiting
with its beak and talons.
Maybe a cardigan
is more appropriate
to his new condition, more
comfortable at any rate.
And seeing that he
no longer goes out
in human society
on a daily basis,
it's surely no longer
necessary for him
to shave every single morning.
Let grow what will.
Just stop putting up resistance.
Or is that how dying begins?
Could dying begin with
this kind of growth?
No, that can't be
right, he thinks.
They still haven't found the
man at the bottom of the lake.
It wasn't suicide.
He died in a swimming accident.
Ever since that day in June,
the lake has been placid.
Day after day, it's been
perfectly calm, calm in June,
calm in July.
And even now with autumn on
the way, it remains calm.
No rowboats, no shrieking
children, no fisherman.
This summer anyone diving
head first off the dock
at the public beach
could only be an outsider
who hasn't heard yet.
While this bather is
drying off after his swim,
a local might address
him who's walking her dog
or a bicyclist who dismounts
for a moment to ask,
so you don't know.
Richard has never
mentioned the accident
to an unsuspecting visitor.
What would be the point?
Why ruin things
for someone who's
just trying to enjoy the day?
Strangers who walk past his
garden gate on their outings
return just as
happy as they came.
But he can't avoid seeing the
lake when he sits at his desk.
Then in the course of
some circumstances, walks
through the city and an
encounter on the Alexanderplatz
first, and yeah,
following other things,
he starts researching on the
issue of refugees and off--
he's researching about
African countries
for the first time, what
are the capitals of these.
And he has not much
of an idea about it.
And his idea is
that he might find,
in the refugees,
the right persons
to ask about the problem of
time, of how to spend time
without being allowed to work.
They are young men mostly.
He is a not a young man anymore.
But the problem is
the same problem.
And so the reason for research
is that he wants to meet them
and to interviewing them
for a project about time.
And so, he is
working out a catalog
of questions that could
make clear the transition,
to explore what the transition
is from one part of life
to another one, which
is hard to stand.
So this just a catalog
of his questions
he prepares for the
first real meeting.
Where did you grow up?
What's your native language?
What's your religious
affiliation?
How many people
are in your family?
What did the apartment or
house you grew up in look like?
How did your parents meet?
Was there a TV?
Where did you sleep?
What did you eat?
What was your favorite hiding
place when you were a child?
Did you go to school?
What sort of clothing
did you wear?
Did you have pets?
Did you learn a trade?
Do you have a
family of your own?
When did you leave the
country of your birth?
Why?
Are you still in contact
with your family?
What was your goal
when you left home?
How did you say your goodbyes?
What did you take with
you when you left?
What did you think
Europe would be like?
What's different?
How do you spend your days?
What do you miss most?
What do you wish for?
If you have children who
were growing up here,
what would you tell them
about your homeland?
Can you imagine
growing old here?
Where do you want to be buried?
And now I am I'm just
reading one of the stories.
He's told by one--
by actually, by
the first refugee,
he's meeting alone
for an interview.
So actually he's meeting
him in a former house
for elderly people, in which the
refugees were put by the Berlin
Senate for a short while.
And there he starts
with his talks.
Avat was born in Ghana.
His mother died giving
birth to him, just
like [INAUDIBLE],,
which are things just
like the mother of Tristan.
The first day of
my life, Avat says,
is also the day
I lost my mother.
And your father?
Avat doesn't answer.
Until the age of seven, he
says, he lived with his Nana,
his grandmother.
Is your grandmother still alive?
Have you seen her since then?
Do you remember
what she looks like?
No.
When Avat was seven
years old, his father
brought him to live in Libya.
This grandmother whose
daughter died giving birth
to her first child
whose grandson learned
to speak from her
and was washed by her
every evening before going
to bed, standing on a board
so that the hot earth
wouldn't burn his feet,
this now very old and
possibly even deceased woman
tries to fight her
way out of the memory
free zone surrounding
her grandson,
fight her way into the world
of all that can be told,
but she doesn't succeed.
Her grandson called her Nana
as Ghanaian grandmothers
are called.
And beyond that,
she has no name.
She remains trapped
in this lower stratum
and silently sings
back down again.
What will the man in the lake
do when the lake freezes over
soon?
Did you ever go back to Ghana?
No, never.
His father worked in Tripoli
as a driver for an oil company.
Avat was sent to school.
They lived alone in
an eight room house.
Often there were guests.
And when his father
got home from work,
he cooked for everyone.
His father played soccer
with him and bought him toys,
gave him pocket money--
quite a lot actually.
He flew with him to
Egypt on vacation.
The flight to Cairo
only took 30 minutes.
I know my way around Cairo
really well, Avat says.
We went over there a lot.
Over there is what West Germany
was called back in GDR times.
Avat's waited until
evening to raise the blinds
on the southern
side of the house
where the sun
shone all day long.
His father taught him how to
dry his bed after a shower
with a towel stretched diago--
oh, this is one of
my favorite words--
diagonally, diagonally.
OK, sorry.
You know, it's not
my mother tongue.
You perhaps realized
that already--
diagonally cross it.
His father taught him
to cook and gave him
his first electric razor.
My father told me
who I am, Avat says.
And then, Avat just sit
silently for a moment,
gazing at the fake wood
vener on the table surface.
This table too may
have stood 25 years ago
in a [SPEAKING GERMAN] office or
in the house of Germans Soviet
Friendship.
But Avat has no way
of knowing this,
and he certainly has
no way of knowing
what [SPEAKING GERMAN] or
German Soviet friendship was.
And then?
I started to work
as an auto mechanic.
I had friends.
It was a good life.
And then?
On the street outside,
a truck was backing up.
You can hear the
warning signal--
a high pitched beeping
sound over and over.
In Morse code, it would be zero.
Every odd week in the
calendar, the plastic recycling
is picked up or maybe
it's a furniture delivery
truck trying to turn
around and in the driveway.
Then my father was shot.
Richard would like to say
something at this point,
but he can't think of anything.
A small yellow label
is affixed to the table
leg, inventory number 360/87.
Richard had seen his father
one last time in the hospital
after his death.
The nurses had bound the
dead man's jaw to his skull
with a bandage to keep his mouth
hanging open for all eternity.
The bandage made his
father look like a nun.
Richard had barely
recognized him.
Avat had bent over,
propping himself on his arms
and gazing ever deeper
into the table surface
as he goes on speaking.
A friend of my
fathers called me.
They were here at the office.
He shouted, your father.
That's all.
I said, I didn't
understand what he meant.
Then he started shouting again,
this man who never shouted,
who was always friendly to me.
Now he was shouting
at me and said
I should run home as fast as
I could and lock the door.
Then the connection was broken
off, and I started running.
But when I got
home, the front door
was already ripped
off its hinges,
the windows were shattered.
Inside everything was
destroyed in the hallway,
two rooms, the kitchen.
There were shots everywhere.
The furniture was upside down.
The TV was messed, everything.
I climbed out one
of the back windows
and tried to call my
father's friend again.
I tried again and again,
but I couldn't get through.
Once I also dialed my
father's number, nothing.
That's how the end was.
Sorry, I'm a bit sick too.
Until night came, I
waited on the street.
Where was I supposed to go?
It was the same street
I walked to go to school
and later to work.
Then a military patrol came.
They forced me to get
in the back of a truck,
and brought me to
a barracks camp.
I saw there people lying
on the street, some of them
shot, others stabbed.
On this day, I saw the war.
There were already hundreds
of people in the barracks.
Most of them were
black Africans,
but there were also some Arabs
from Tunisia, Morocco, Egypt--
not only men, but also women,
children, babies, old people.
They took everything away from
us-- money, watches, phones,
even our socks, he says--
and starts laughing.
He laughs and laughs.
It's not easy, he says,
and stops laughing.
It's not easy, he says
again, shaking his head.
It's not easy, as if this
were the end of the story.
And then, when I
tried to complain,
he says they hit me in the
head with a rifle butt.
You can still see the scar.
Avat parts his hair
with his fingers
and shows the car to
the Professor Emeritus
with whom he is speaking today
for the first time in his life.
If you want to arrive somewhere,
you can't hide anything,
he had said to Richard
at the beginning
of their conversation.
If you are lucky,
you'll get beaten.
If you're unlucky,
you'll get shot,
someone said to console me.
Then they took the Sim
cards out of all phones
and destroyed them
before our eyes.
They broke the
memory, Avat says.
None of us had anything
left except a t-shirt
or pants or a skirt.
For two days, we sat
there in the barracks
while the European
bombs fell on Tripoli.
We were afraid one of
the bombs would hit us
since it was a military camp.
On the third day, they
brought us to the harbor
and made us get on a boat.
Who among you knows how
to steer a boat like this.
Two or three Arabs
said they did.
They raised the Gaddafi
flag and our boat,
Avat says laughing,
a Gaddafi flag.
So whether they're
Gaddafi people or rebels,
we didn't know.
They all had the same uniforms.
Before this moment, Richard
had never really thought
that members of the military who
turned against the government
would still be viewing
their country's uniform.
In any case, no one
was on our side.
Even though I grew up in
Libya, Libya was my country.
Avat nods to himself.
And for a while, he
says nothing more.
And then, then they shot a
salvo in the air and said to us,
anyone who tries to
swim back will be shot.
We didn't know where the
boat was going, maybe
to Malta or Tunisia.
Only later did we understand
it was going to Italy.
We were squeezed in so
tight you could only
get up for a few minutes.
Then you sat down again right
where you were sitting before.
The woman behind me
peed without getting up.
When I tried to prop myself
up, everything was wet.
We were in the
boat for four days.
There were only a
few bottles of water,
and we gave them
to the children.
When things got too bad,
we adults drank salt water.
It's not easy, Richard.
It's not easy.
We made a bigger hole in
an empty plastic bottle
with our teeth.
And then we tied together
a couple of shoelaces,
attached the bottle,
and let it over the side
to scoop up the seawater.
You have to drink a
few people [AUDIO OUT]
My head, my head, and then
bent his head like this.
And then the next
moment he was dead.
When people died, we
threw them in the water.
Richard thinks about
all the airplanes
from which he's looked out over
window at some sea or other,
how the waves seen from above
appear not to be moving at all
and the white foam
looks like stone.
In the middle of the
previous century,
the Libyan coast briefly
belonged to Italy.
Now Libya is a
different country.
And to refugees
who leave by boat,
Italy appears first in form
of a small, rocky elevation
surrounded by a
great deal of water
if it appears to them at all.
War destroys
everything, Avat says--
your family, your friends,
the place where you live,
your work, your life.
When you become foreign, Avat
says, you don't have a choice.
You don't know where to go.
You don't know anything.
I can't see myself anymore,
can't see the child
I used to be.
I don't have a picture
of myself anymore.
My father is dead, he says.
And me, I don't know
who I am anymore.
Becoming foreign to
yourself and others,
that's what the
transition looks like.
What's the sense of all this,
he asks, looking back at Richard
again.
Now Richard is the one
who's supposed to answer,
but he doesn't know how.
Isn't it like this, Avat says--
every adult human being,
man or woman, rich or poor,
if he has work or not,
if he lives in a house
or is homeless,
it doesn't matter.
Every human being has
a few years to live,
and then he dies?
Yes, that's how it
is, Richard says.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Now you can hear us.
Everybody can hear us?
Me, too?
Yeah?
OK.
Good.
Let's hope.
Can you hear Jenny?
No.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
I cannot hear you.
Ah, yes.
You'll have to talk
into your chin.
Wait.
I put it a bit closer, otherwise
I will have to speak like this.
And that's not very polite.
Wait, wait, wait.
Doesn't look so bad.
OK, now it's a bit better.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] a bit?
No, it's not quite
perfect, but it's better.
That's good.
I try my best to speak like this
like someone from the Secret
Service.
You want put it on inside
so when you're talking--
My inside?
On the other side so that
when you're speaking to the--
That's a good idea.
Then you'll be
turning naturally.
This was quite clever.
I hope it doesn't fall down.
OK, it's good.
Now it's perfect.
I can hear me speaking.
You can hear you.
Good.
So I guess you can hear me, too.
Sorry for you.
It's not unpolite to this
side, but to the mic is here.
Thank you for that
wonderful reading.
And there are so many
things to talk about.
Maybe that's as good a place--
how about the story is as
good as any to start perhaps?
And to ask you, I know you did
a lot of research for this book.
How did this book come to be?
What was the germ of it?
Where did it start?
And how did you embark on
discovering and telling--
I mean-- these stories?
And how fictionalized are they?
And all of those questions.
Where did the book come from?
Let's start there.
[SPEAKING GERMAN],, actually
the reason for starting
was, I was about to write
another book in autumn 2013.
And there was one of
the first big accidents.
One of those refugee
boats capsized,
and hundreds of people drowned.
And the next day, I opened
a German newspapers.
And I thought that they would
write something like, that's
a tragedy, of course.
And they wrote a bit like
this, but only a bit.
And mostly they said, yes, but
accidents like these cannot be
a reason to accept all of
the refugees in Europe,
that all people think
they can come to Europe.
And for me, this seemed to
be an inappropriate reaction.
And I thought, this was--
it shocked me because it made
so clear that the value of life
is so different, that the
value of a life of a refugee
much less--
or is considered to be much
less than life in Europe
or in the world we know.
We-- OK, we could speak
about it, how we too.
But we don't do so now.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
and then, I thought,
as you said in your introduction
also, in Germany and of course
also in the US, we grew up with
these stories of surviving,
of people that only survive
because one single person had
helped them to be in
a place or somewhere,
all the fascist
time stories, these
were the stories that
like made my education.
And so I thought
there's not much
of a difference, especially
this chapter I've read.
I was told the
story by a refugee,
and this story reminded
me of many, many stories
s for instance, the trains in
which the Jews were brought
to the concentration camps.
It's not much of a
difference in the suffering,
and during that transport.
So I thought, it's
time that someone
from out of the middle of the
society starts to deal with it
and to ask, who are
these people and what
are they really are
thinking and doing
while waiting in Europe for a
chance to be allowed to work,
that the main problem is that
they are not allowed to work--
not that they
don't want to work,
but that they are not allowed.
Only in the country
where they'll end
up first, which in most cases--
Is Italy.
Is Italy, Greece,
or Spain, and we all
know that these are not the
countries with the strongest
economy.
And in Germany, we
are lacking people,
but we don't want to have these
refugees because they are not
well educated enough
in most of the cases.
And somehow there's
no idea of giving them
some years for perhaps
learning something, which--
[SPEAKING GERMAN] we
can can do this later.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
so I thought, OK, I
put aside the book I
already had started.
And then I thought,
OK, I just started.
And then I went--
So did you know right away--
when you read that article
in the paper and you felt,
what then must we do,
was your first thought,
I must like Richard go and
find out who these people are
and what's going on or
was your first thought I
must write a novel?
What was the thinking one?
I must write a novel.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] yeah, my
idea was, I must write a novel.
So I could also
give German lessons.
But I thought I should do--
But you do.
--what I like to do and
what I'm here for, perhaps.
I don't know.
You never know.
Only in the end.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] and then I
went into the middle of things.
I just started to make contact
with a group of refugees.
They had been living
in tents for 2 years
by then on a square in Berlin,
in the middle of Berlin.
And this was where
I first met them.
And I'm--
Sorry, and this would be 2013?
This was 2014.
So first, I asked Richard.
I did some reading
and researching.
And then it's like you cannot
imagine how far it is even
if it's in your own city to
make a contact or to just appear
and say, hello, I'm going to
write a novel or something like
that, which really seems to be
a completely stupid sentence
in this surrounding.
And the refugees,
they had been object
to films, documentary
films or short interviews
before, or like
sometimes journalists
would pass by and write an
article or something like that.
They knew that there are
some people also interested
in their fears.
But they had no idea
what a novel is for.
And so they thought,
after a few weeks,
they thought the novel
should be finished soon.
Some weeks passed, and
I come again and again.
And what's going on?
The real talks
started when I went
in the house for
the elderly people,
were Richard also
meets them by chance.
And so they spent some
months in this house,
and then they were
brought somewhere else.
And then they were sent out
to the street, back to Italy.
And I always followed them
to all of these places.
And then when they were
sent out to the streets,
some would applied to
the church for help,
and they provided some shelter.
At church?
[INAUDIBLE] places at
church, but only for a few.
And then we would also--
me and my friends would
also try to do our best to--
[SPEAKING GERMAN],, meanwhile we
knew all of them quite well--
so like 10, 15
people were known.
And of course, if someone
who was your kind of friend
and he's calling you,
saying, this night
I have to leave the house
and I don't know where to go,
you also have a problem.
And so it was much
less stress than they
had because I was lying in
my bed in my nice apartment
and with a nice
family and everything.
But even for me,
it was stressful.
And for them, it was, of
course, even more stressful.
So in the course of all this--
and this was the idea
also of the book.
It was not only about collecting
refugees, dramatic refugees,
stories, and putting
them into a book.
The idea was to connect
both worlds that
are so far away from each
other even when in one city.
So I could feel, when
writing the book in German,
it took me 30 pages before
the first encounter could
take place.
And for me, this was a sign
that it's really far away.
So 30 pages, that's
for a first encounter
of the main characters.
It's long.
I was writing and writing.
And writing is always, you don't
know how long the way will be.
You just start until
you see it takes time.
It cannot be like this.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
in the beginning
it was Richard or in a way
me interviewing the refugees.
But after some weeks and months,
it became a new kind of present
that we were sharing--
so experiences that connected
in a way both worlds.
Of course I'm
always much happier,
and after the worst
experiences, I
could always go and have
a nice [SPEAKING GERMAN]..
What is it?
Dinner.
But it was funny,
not really funny.
But in a way, also funny
that by accompanying
the refugees to all these
offices and the lawyer,
and doctors, and
the asylum seekers
office, or the
foreigners office,
or whatever office Germany
has invented for this problem,
I explored my own
society, the own society
was the foreign country.
This was funny in a way.
And so this that
this became the book.
I put that the
talks into the book,
but I also put all these
experiences into the book.
And Richard, to start, as a
very proper German professor,
retired professor, interviewing
people, all of a sudden
he finds himself
involved in things
he never had dreamed of before.
So for him, it's kind of a
new life of a strange kind.
It also makes him rethink or
recast his entire conception
of his profession.
I mean, he's a
classics professor.
And suddenly, he's
revisiting all of the myths
and the classical characters.
And his whole world, his whole
understanding of the world,
has shifted by these encounters.
Yeah, he remembers all of a
sudden that the Greek gods--
some of them are
based in North Africa.
So he sees there always has
been a connection of his culture
to the culture of
the people that
now come from the Northern
African countries.
He starts thinking about
the Greeks having learned--
he's [INAUDIBLE] saying so that
they learn the art of horse--
Charioteering.
Yeah, this, I think that--
Yeah, [SPEAKING GERMAN].
They learned it from
the [? Baba ?] people.
So even the Greeks
weren't first at all.
So there was a
beginning earlier.
And so he's learning much about
the like 3,000 or 4,000 years
of culture of the [? Tourek. ?]
And just weeks ago, I
was in Morocco and I saw a map.
And perhaps you know this map,
by [? Idriso, ?] from the 10th
century, around 1000.
He has made a map which
has not the north on top
but the south on top,
which is really good to see
for our point of view.
And this is a bit
like what Richard
is experiencing in the book.
So South Africa is on top,
and Europe is somewhere
on the bottom.
Si it's not that important
anymore if it's down.
That makes me think
of a line that I
think is Richard's
thought in the novel--
to understand what a
person means or says,
it's basically necessary
to already know what
that person means or is saying.
So is every successful dialogue
just an act of recognition
and is understanding not
a path but a condition?
And I wanted to
ask you about that
because, if that were
true, there wouldn't
be a lot of hope for all of us.
For your professors.
But just generally, I
mean, our nation right now,
for the world--
but it seems as though the
novel has a more optimistic view
in a way because, I mean,
they're living in translation.
Half the time they're speaking
Italian to one another.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
it's not optimistic?
No.
I think it's always like waiting
for the right moment to happen.
So that reflection
is an optimistic one?
Yeah.
OK, because that's not how
I was reading it as saying
that basically unless you--
so if you and I mean something
different by dinner or love
or family, we have
different meanings.
Then I took that
statement to be saying
we could never
understand one another
because we would have
to already understand
what that person, what you--
I would have to
already understand
what you were saying in
order to understand you.
This would mean it always
has to be exactly the same
to make it possible to
understand someone else.
But this is not what I mean.
What I mean is that you
are like prepared or open
to think in the pattern
of someone else, to--
So it is optimistic.
Yeah, it's optimistic.
It's optimistic.
OK, good.
OK, well, that's a relief.
Because another thing
going through the--
I mean, certainly established at
the beginning from the section
that Jenny read, there's
that body in the water.
There is that body
under the lake.
And very soon after that,
there's the reference
to the subterranean passages
under Alexanderplatz and also
in the Polish village, the
name of which I cannot say.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
R-Z, it involves--
I wrote it down.
[INAUDIBLE] what's the name?
[SOUNDS] It involved
many s's and z's.
Wait, wait, wait.
You spell it R-Z-E-S-Z--
Rzeszów, Rzeszów,
Rzeszów, Rzeszów, Rzeszów.
But he thinks about
that the [INAUDIBLE]
like underneath Alexanderplatz.
Somebody calls to us from afar
there from underneath the lake.
There are the vestiges
of preexisting towns,
really subterranean towns
where people have taken
refuge in difficult times.
But what abides
for this reader is
the sense of the
world under the world,
this world under the surface.
And then the question is
how you have access to it
and whether just
listening is enough.
Is listening enough?
[SPEAKING GERMAN] so when we
are speaking about how to learn,
I think listening is not enough.
So my father is a philosopher,
and his special issue just now
is competence, which might
sound very common nowadays.
But he says it's learning
always only takes place or is
done by own experience.
If the thing or the subject
or whatever you are learning
is not connected
to your emotion,
it will not stay with you.
So you can be in love
with your professor,
but you can also
be very interested
because of your family's
history or whatever reason might
be the connection but
to be mostly emotionally
connected to you
to make you learn.
And so it'd be your
own experience.
So for me, it was only to--
you can read the
refugee stories also
in newspapers-- well
written, well written,
and moving and everything.
But when you start sharing--
no, not sharing, not
sharing, but taking
parts of the life
of refugees, you
see all the waiting, all the
empty time they have to spend,
and all the really complicated
and, in my eyes, a bit or a bit
more stupid laws
that forbid them
to work or to make an
apprenticeship or go to school.
If they arrive
older than 18, they
are not allowed to
go enter a school
and to be taken care for.
But if they come in the age of
17, they are put in the school
and they get people
caring for them.
And then 18, OK, we
want to get rid of you.
Please leave and go
home in your country.
So do these things, if you are
experiencing by seeing them
again and again like I did,
it makes a big difference
because it's so really
really, really hard to--
and the surviving is not
only the moment of being safe
at this or that cost.
It's the surviving
stays hard for years.
Some of my refugees, they
would get weird ideas.
One of them said to me, I think
here is no one wanting me.
I have no place where I
can put my head for sleep.
I will go to the
[SPEAKING GERMAN]..
The Foreign Legion,
the Foreign Legion.
Foreign Legion.
It's one of the worst
troops one could go it.
But also, because
then they'd want
to go back and be
a mercenary in--
[SPEAKING GERMAN],, and then
I said, what do you want?
And he said, ah,
a friend told me
they have such a
good sports program.
OK, that's a reason for a young
man to join this kind of force.
And he's a lovely boy.
So he has no idea that he's
a killer or someway, who
wants to shoot people.
And I pretended to be
his mom and forbid.
But there are many, many others
that no one is listening to,
no one is taking care.
No one is saying, like
a mom, you don't do so.
Many of them have either
left their families
or they have lost
their families.
They have no one
taking care for them.
They have no money of course.
They cannot found a family.
They have often very strict
ideas about first having a job,
then having money,
then founding a family.
And if they can't do so,
they won't have a family.
They are missing
children in their lives.
These are all big,
big problems that are
growing in the course of years.
So you referred to them as your
refugee, my refugees, you said.
So your refugees, now four
years later, where are they now?
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
One became mad.
And I think he ended--
ended, I don't know--
but he's in psychiatry in Italy.
But I couldn't find
out where exactly
and how he is because
I'm not a family member
and I'm not given
information about it.
So I guess he's still there.
And his father didn't
send the papers for him
that he could be returned
to his home country
because his father has
the opinion that it would
be better for him in Europe.
So this is of the--
So he's institutionalized
in Italy.
And it seemed to the
church people and to me
that his madness somehow has
to do with abuse in Europe,
that he was abused by some man.
Sometimes he was
full of fear when
he was alone with
this very nice man
from the church
who cared for him.
Then he would ask him,
what do you want from me.
And so, it was our impression
that he experienced bad things
in Europe, not only in
Africa, during the war.
And then my main character
of the group, who I always
used to call the president of
this group, [SPEAKING GERMAN]
in the refugees heaven.
Zeus?
In English we say Zeus.
That's who you mean?
Yeah, Zeus.
I speak ancient Greek, Zeus.
And unfortunately he died.
He died 1 and 1/2 years ago by
a heart stroke, heart attack.
And this was also not
what we really wanted
him to experience in Europe.
And then some others,
now in last autumn
they got permission to stay
with a license to look for work.
This is the happy.
So that's three years it
took them, three years.
No, now it's eight--
he's 17, four years.
Four years, or four or
five years for some.
And only because the church
fought so hard for them
and there are some
commissions and so--
but it was, as
far as I know now,
it's perhaps for 50 of
450, something like that.
It's a small percentage.
And the poor guy who was
given a set by us privately--
so he was not a member of
the so-called church group.
So he will never,
ever get a document.
Oh, really?
So on and so on.
And one got here, Avat,
he got a kind of a-- it's
called [SPEAKING GERMAN]
in Germany.
This means that he's
allowed to stay,
but only because of his bad
mental health condition,
he has been traumatized.
So it's like saying,
we don't want you here
and you are not really
allowed to work.
And the foreign
office can always
say no to whatever
offer he gets.
He has to apply with an offer.
And they can say no, and
they don't have the reasons.
And then he goes
to the next job--
And applies and they say no.
And takes the offer in the
asylum seekers foreigners'
offices, no, and
so on and so on.
So we organized a nice
apartment for him,
and there's he just sitting.
He's hanging out.
But there's not much
of a perspective.
And this is one of
the stupid things.
It's nice to give someone
who has a problem of whatever
kind to give him the
permission to stay,
but of course you can wait for
years that this person will
become well again.
If you are saying that the next
thing we will do as soon as you
are well again is
sending you back home.
Right, is deport you.
This doesn't make sense.
There's one alcoholic.
It's so funny.
The German system is really--
it's nice in a way,
but so the alcoholic
got permission to stay
because he's ill with his
being an alcoholic.
But of course, they can
wait for a 100 years to--
But he has not much
incentive to quit the habit.
[INAUDIBLE]
But it's a recurring
line from the book
about dead men on a holiday--
it's citing, was he
a French communist
or was he a German
communist who was being--
Yeah, he's a French name.
--who was arrested
and sentenced to death
and who described
his fellow communists
and himself as dead
men on holiday.
And that's an analogy in
the book to the situation
of the refugees who have lost--
what's the difference
between dying on the boat
and living afterwards?
This rift between your
former life and everything
that you knew and this
stateless, contextless
situation of uncertainty
that you live in?
I mean, there's
so much to discuss
in terms of the reality
of the situation.
I also want to talk, though,
about the making of art
about this situation and whether
it was a different experience
than writing your other books,
whether structurally you
approached it in
a different way,
whether you were able to write
about it while you were also
dealing with people
in their lives
or whether you had to
step back from that
and have some
distance from the work
you were doing with the refugees
in order to write about it.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] the luxury
of waiting for the distance,
I didn't have.
You didn't have.
But as a writer, you always
have a bit of a difference--
a distance.
Yeah, there are some differences
between the former book
and this book, but in my eyes
the things they have in common
is like my interest in
the way of biography,
the way of the difference of
which is made just by chance,
by chance [SPEAKING GERMAN]?
Chance, you mean literally
like you might turn left
or you might turn right and
that can change everything.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] and
this I saw clearly also
in dealing with these
biographies of the refugees.
And if you mentioned that
some people are drowning
and some people are
saved, you will always
see the dead and the living
and the living and the dead.
So it's not for me.
It's not like two worlds apart.
I see it in the same moment
that all these people
that I met as real persons,
that they could have easily
been also on the ground
of the Mediterranean Sea
and that at the ground
there are so many
like my friends
that I know so well now.
And yeah, and the
question of transition.
Perhaps I will never
understand what a transition is
and how it happens
because one is living
a normal life in
Libya, for instance,
and then he's crossing
the Mediterranean Sea.
And then he's someone else.
But he's still
himself or herself.
So he keeps something
with him or with her,
which what makes his identity.
But he loses so many things that
also are part of his identity
that it's very
hard to say who is.
This was one of the main
points Avat made clear for me.
And it's worth talking to
people that have so much life
experience because it's--
this I only understood
when I talked to him
that you're not only losing
your country or your family,
which is bad enough.
You are also losing yourself
and the system in which
makes sense.
And this is a problem.
If there's no new structure
you can start with,
it will be very, very
hard to build you anew
from all the tiny
things around you,
as you wrote in your book--
the puzzle, the puzzle.
Yeah, it's all the
pieces that go--
The pieces of the puzzle.
Yes, that go together
to make you who you are.
There are so many
things that come
to mind and so many stories.
And I mean, I feel the case of
the refugees is an extreme one.
It is an extreme case
of that situation.
But of course it's true,
I mean, in this country
where almost everyone
comes from somewhere else,
if not in the first
generation, then before.
It's an ongoing-- it's
less radical a rupture,
but it's an ongoing complication
of how do you communicate
or can you communicate what
is beneath the surface.
Does it matter?
And I think often--
the novel ends with
Richard saying,
I'd look at the surface, I
realize, because I can't bear--
I wrote the line down.
I think that's when
I realized, says
Richard, that the
things I can endure
are only just the surface of
what I can't possibly endure,
like the surface of the sea,
asked [? Khalil. ?] Actually,
yes, exactly like the
surface of the sea.
And there's some way in
which in our lives each day
we deal only with that
surface because we somehow
can't contend with all
that lies beneath it.
In the case of the refugees,
that brings you back
to the quote I was
citing earlier, which
I was saying was pessimistic.
But I want to hold
onto your optimism,
but it is this question
of how can these--
when you lose all that context--
when we were outside before
and I said two words in German,
you said, oh, I
see you differently
when you speak in German.
And what translation
does to each of us.
My father was French,
and I speak French.
But I'm just not
very funny in French.
And I feel like being
funny is important to me.
So I always want
who am I, who am
I in French when I'm not funny.
But imagine, for Avat, how
much is not translatable
and especially when he
and Richard or he and you,
I don't know, but are
speaking in Italian,
say, in a language
that is foreign to--
that is a mediated language,
a sort of foreign language
for both of them.
It's both miraculous and--
Yeah, but the understanding
is bigger than the language.
So if you are able
to understand it all,
you can understand just
by looking at someone.
Or you will understand.
It's not a question of language.
In a way, it's also a
question of language,
but it's [SPEAKING GERMAN]
There where these small pieces
of sugar in Germany, and there
would be written something
like a prophecy, what you are
and it depends--
Sort of like a fortune
cookie or something.
--which pieces of sugar you got.
And I got one.
I got a piece of sugar,
and there was written,
you are good mediator.
A good medium, a medium, a
good medium, a good medium.
And so, perhaps I think
sometimes [INAUDIBLE] the one
who wanted to join the Foreign--
Legion.
Foreign Legion.
He normally would say
words like, oh, cool, wow.
So he's a normal young man.
But I can see behind this.
I can see behind and sometimes--
also by language, but somehow
he told me his life story.
And then he was very serious.
And then there was a moment when
he got his birth certificate.
And for the first time, he
saw the names of his parents.
He never knew his parents.
And this was like he doesn't
need to tell me a story.
He just comes with
his birth certificate
showing me the names of her
parents saying, and look,
I'm a year younger than
I thought, like this.
And then there's a
whole world behind it,
and you can understand it.
And you see that behind this
person who's saying, hey, cool,
there's someone else.
And he has a lot of
experience in the way he's
dealing with the difficult
situations in his group,
in which he's staying
now for four years,
like 10 people in one room
at the moment now and so on.
And here you could
see that in a way
he's wise, but not
in terms of language,
not in terms of language.
And that's good.
And so if someone
is touching you,
then your experience
is also growing
and you just understand.
You get with the question.
You get the instrument.
But it's also-- I think I'm
reminded as you're talking--
I remember as a
child playing with--
I remember playing
for hours with a girl,
and she and I didn't
speak the same language.
But we didn't feel as
though we didn't when
an entire day went by and we
had a great time together.
And we felt as though we
spoke the same language,
even though we didn't
have any words in common.
In a minute, I want everybody
here to have a chance
to ask questions.
But I just wanted to--
just thinking
about another thing
that you've said in an interview
actually seems relevant to me
here because history is so
important in all your work.
And here it's these
histories that
come out as if from
under the surface
that Richard hasn't known and
he does this extra research.
Because he's an academic, he
goes and reads about the Torah,
and he learns about things.
But you've said, I
think history infects
the lives, the very
private lives of people.
So you cannot remove
something from history,
even if you just
want to tell a story.
And I suppose for me that
raises all sorts of questions
that I'd love to
hear you speak about.
One is whether you think it's--
I mean, I think you're saying
it's not possible to write
something that's outside--
that doesn't have the great
weight of history around it.
And I wonder if that feels
to you a general state.
We sit here in a room
full of Americans
for whom this regarding history
is a sport and a pastime.
And I've only spent
one year in Berlin,
but history is all around.
You can't turn away from it.
You can't escape it.
And I guess I wondered
to what extent you feel--
this will seem a
pivot in a way--
that you feel that you are not
just a contemporary writer,
but a contemporary
German writer,
whether you feel you're
a contemporary writer--
a German writer with an
East German heritage,
whether you feel that all
of those things shape you
or whether you feel you're
a freer agent in a way--
it's just how that
presence of history
plays for you in your work and
in your conception of your work
and of yourself.
Just a little question.
When I started writing,
I didn't know that I
was interested in history.
And I always started at
some very concrete point
that interested me, and
it turned out to be--
as you said, I ended
up in the middle
of the European
or German history.
And this might also be because--
so one side of my
family, my mother's side,
they were living
in nowadays Poland.
And at the end of
the war, the women
moved to the
nowadays German part.
And my grandmother, was before
she was taken and brought
to a prisoners camp in Siberia,
or just taken from the street
and put into a train.
And she spent like
half a year in Siberia,
and she made it
back, fortunately.
So this was one
part of my family.
The other part was
my father's side.
My grandparents were communists.
This is one of the
bigger sins in the US.
But I always felt very proud
to have had grandparents
that fought against
the fascist regime,
and I'm still proud of it.
And they had to leave Germany
right from the beginning.
When Hitler was elected,
they left for Prague
and then went to
the Soviet Union.
And they also survived the
Stalin time, the dark years
of the 30s when
communists were killed
by other communists, which
didn't make any sense at all.
And they made it back.
So in both parts of my family,
there is the German history--
Right there.
--right there.
So even if I would like
to avoid these stories,
I couldn't because they are
stories of leaving things
behind, of only taking one
suitcase, and the question
how to save the children and
who will make it back and how
and also the question
of surviving.
My father was born
in the immigration,
and not many babies
survived this time.
So it was always the
luck that made us.
Yeah, so as it turned out,
this is part of my life too.
And do you feel, in some
way, do you feel at all--
these are obviously
personal stories--
but do you feel, in some
way, a sort of responsibility
as a German writer to
tell certain stories
or to fill in certain gaps
in the literary history?
Or do you feel you're
part of a community
or a chorus of writers or?
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
I must confess,
the only responsibility I feel
is to write what interests me.
So I think if I'm lucky, someone
else is also interested in it.
It seems like we are.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] but the main
thing for me is that there is
something that is interesting
enough to need time to think
about, and the writing is a way
to deal with it and to add to--
like build a
complex, what is it?
Entity of things that
are working together
in a sense that perhaps
no one expected.
So at the end of days or--
yeah, I think the
most interesting thing
is to change the
perspective again and again
and again and not to
put your attention only
to the things in the
middle, like that someone is
politically engaged and
he's suffering whatever.
Perhaps there's a
tiny little detail
in the beginning of the
life of the main character
and there's a tiny
little detail.
And perhaps this makes the
sense of the whole life
and to the end when she is 90
and all the things in between,
like the love, and the
political engagement,
and being famous, and
sitting in Harvard.
All this perhaps it's not
the most important thing,
and perhaps it was
important that I
put a stone from the
earth, when I was a child--
I don't know.
You never know.
And this interests very much.
It's going to make
me ask one l--
sorry, everybody, one last
question, and then I'm
going to turn it over to you.
Now where did they go?
Where did it go?
It's on page-- it's where it
says, where he says, page 16.
And I want to ask you
about the balance between--
as writers, we
deal in the matter
of sort of chairs and tables and
cups of coffee and underwear,
and then also
somehow in the matter
of the metaphysical or
the existential questions
or the great themes of history.
And he says-- I'm just going
to read you guys a little bit--
he slices onions for the salad.
He's been slicing
onions all his life,
but just recently he saw
in a cookbook the best way
to hold the onion to
keep it from sliding out
from under the knife.
There's an ideal
form for everything,
not just in matters
of work and art
but also for the most
mundane ordinary things.
When it comes down
to it, he thinks
we probably spend
our entire lives just
trying to attain this form.
And when you finally achieved
it in a few different areas,
you get wiped off the planet.
So, again, I feel like
you're going to tell me
that's an optimistic statement.
And I am going to believe you.
But I just wanted to ask you
about navigating because you
really are tackling--
I mean, you have a very
complex sentence of form.
You have a complex sentence
of the use of metaphor.
You're writing novels
that, in each case,
involve chopping onions or
moving stools or wearing coats
or whatever it is but are also
about these much bigger themes.
And I just wanted to
ask you how much--
how consciously you have
to strike that balance
or whether it's intuitive,
whether it just comes naturally
or whether there's
something you can
impart to the audience
about how you go about it.
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
Mostly just right, and it
just comes as it comes.
But sometimes-- I remember
complaining to my husband,
saying, oh, today now
it's really enough.
I wrote too much plot.
I have to get rid of
this writing plot.
It's enough.
It's so boring,
and it's so banal.
So, OK.
But of course, a book a needs a
kind of people doing something
or like entering the room
before they can speak at least
or whatever.
Reinhard was pretty good at
having people do very little.
You can have a whole book
where somebody opens the door
and goes into a
room and that's it.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] But
there were other days when
I would complain about the
opposite, saying, oh, god
there was too much philosophy.
I can't stand the
philosophy anymore,
and this is really boring.
And it's [INAUDIBLE],,
and I have to stop it.
So it's a mixed of both,
and I think it's always
good to come back to--
first, to have a
good imagination,
but to leave out everything
which is not really necessary.
So I was studying
theater in the beginning,
and we learned that every
scene that is not necessary you
can be cut.
So all of my novels are also a
cut version of a theater play,
so to say.
So I only leave
inside what I really
need because all other
things are boring
and are slowing the whole thing.
And it's not good.
And yeah, yeah.
So do you write do you
write longer and then cut?
Or do you just cut as you go?
You know it's dispensable.
I cut in my head.
That's very efficient.
That's great.
I do.
Yeah, this is my thickest book.
In Germany, it's a bit bigger.
And yeah, I like to cut.
And I don't want to be bored.
I'm my first reader.
And if I get bored,
something is wrong.
And yeah, my mother
always used to say,
so what did you want to say.
This and that.
Then say it.
Then tell it.
Be clear and not--
Or my husband once--
he's Austrian.
Sometimes he's in Austria.
So we are calling each other,
and then I'm reading him
some passages I have finished.
And I read to him a
passage, and then he
would say, ah, it's good.
It's good.
But somehow it's a
bit too much art.
There's something wrong with it.
It's too much art.
And I kept this in mind because,
if there's too much art,
I'm happy.
I can do a lot if I
want to, but I wouldn't.
If it's not necessary,
you shouldn't--
tell the people what you
want to tell and that's it.
As a friend of mine says, state
your needs and move to closure.
Not quite, but thank you.
So now maybe it's time--
if you guys would like to
come to the microphones,
if people have questions, by
all means come and ask away.
Some people may need to leave.
If people don't have a
question, beware, I'm
going to ask another.
Do come.
Sorry.
Thank you very much.
A number of things
came to my mind.
And amongst them, I wanted
to know, first of all,
what do you think the Germans
learnt from the Nazi period?
What do you think the
lessons of the Nazi period
were for this particular
refugee moment where--
this is a question I was
asked on Munich Television.
So I'm asking you
now how to answer.
I don't think did a good job,
but I was asked this in Munich.
So what do you think
that experience has done?
Because looking at the
situation from America
or the Gulf or many
other countries other
than the African
countries, we think
that the Germans have done
better than most in this way.
The whole hospitality to
the refugees is problematic,
but I think that there was
something that they learnt
deeply about minorities.
Doesn't mean that
it's disseminated
through the country.
But the fact that Germany
stands out in Europe
says something to me
about that past history,
given the history that
you also talked about,
and how it might have
created a change now
despite the absurdities of
the law that you mentioned.
So that's the first
question I wanted to ask.
And the other one goes
from the other side, which
is that you have very
carefully shown in the book,
but also in this
conversation, how
in order to be
able to empathize,
the issue is not simply about
translation and language,
it's about a kind of existential
or phenomenological empathy,
that somebody shows
you something small
and you see what's behind it.
How can that be communicated to
people who are anti refugees?
What work must be
done to create that?
What institutions
must put in place?
You talked about the Church.
What other kind-- and that
is an institutional moment.
What other kinds
of things do you
think society must do to be
able to create this unspoken,
not necessarily
accurately translated
relationship of coexistence.
OK, these are really--
Two, small, light questions.
The first question I
would say that it's
true the Germans seem to
have learned a lot from what
their ancestors did wrong
some 50, 60, 70 years--
no, a bit more--
70 years ago.
The problem was that somehow it
was left to the private people
to be solved.
And of course, the things
that are not enabled by law,
cannot be enabled
by private persons.
All help doesn't make any
sense if someone is not allowed
to stay and to apply for work.
[INAUDIBLE]
And many, many private people
that did very, very good
work and started
teaching refugees.
All of them came to this
border off of the law
because there were not--
for the Assyrians, we made some
exceptions, but because they
were educated of course also.
But for the Africans were
not made any exceptions.
And there was not even--
I wouldn't say it was
not even because nobody
knew about Libya,
but it was also
because people, like
the politicians,
knew what happened in Libya.
And the Africans, at
least my group, they
were the victims
of the wrong side
because, in Libya, the
revolution started.
This was something glorious,
and that the revolution
produced victims, nobody
didn't want to hear.
They were the victims
of the wrong side,
which is also something one
can think about a long time.
And the other question is
more difficult to Answer.
It's not so easy to say we
know what is right and wrong,
and we only have to bring all
people to our state of mind,
which is the right one.
This is a difficult thing to do.
The people that are
aggressive against refugees,
now especially in East Germany,
and also in West Germany,
but more unfortunately
East Germany,
I think this is not a
question of teaching.
This is a question of how--
so what experiences they made
during the fall of the wall,
after the fall of the war,
how little the respect was
for their have biographies,
how little their respect was
for their achievements, and
how little their chances where
on the West German market.
So this is not just
about speaking to them,
telling them you should
accept the refugees.
Also it should start earlier,
or we should go back in history.
But we can't.
This is a problem.
But there is--
sorry, [INAUDIBLE]
there is a problem
with that, as much
as I agreed with you,
that these conditions have
effects, when you
yourself had treated
your own country
like a foreigner,
as many East Germans
were [INAUDIBLE]..
They were treated as if they
came from the global south,
they were foreigners,
they were outside.
Of course, it's going
to have an effect.
But when you lay so much
store on experience,
I can see that working
brilliantly in a novel.
But it's difficult
always to say as you just
said that [INAUDIBLE]
has to start much before
or be that we've got to be able
to have the experience in order
to be able to create a politics.
So I think that is
difficult. And by the way,
the example of the onion
was a platonic allegory--
there has to be perfect
way of cutting the onion.
So I just think that this notion
of how experience is structured
into change, or transformation,
in a moment of crisis
is very important idea
of yours on trying
to understand transition.
Yeah.
It's difficult.
The difficult thing
is that, if you have 100 people
that make the same experience,
they will behave themselves in
100 different ways afterwards.
And this is also--
for Richard as it is
for me, the experience
of being somehow like a stranger
after the fall of the wall
just turned me into someone
who feels empathy for people
that are strange somewhere.
But other people,
they would just
keep the fear of a
breakdown, of a break
down of a whole society.
And it's also a family
question of generations.
And this is also what brought
me to write the book because I
think it's so short-sighted
to think only about
now, how to solve
the problem, where
to put all these refugees.
The best would be that
they stay in Africa.
It's a problem of generations,
of the next three and four
and five generations, as I can
see from my family's story.
And it's also how the
experience is communicated
within the families.
So if someone his job
after the fall of the war,
he will have been
full of disappointment
about the West and his
hopes and perhaps he
was happy in the first moment.
And then he was the
idiot in the end,
and he would communicate this
experience to his children,
to his grandchildren, and there
will be a hatred kept alive
in the families.
And this was very
hard-- for instance,
there was never ever, in a
way I was happy about it,
but in a way, I was also
disappointed-- there was never
ever a Nazi in one
of my readings,
and I really had a lot
of readings in Germany.
And there was no one to
really discuss against me,
which was in a way a relief.
But it was also a pity that
there is not even a talk.
Thank you.
You were speaking-- one of the
things that really moves me
about the book is that
Richard is from GDR,
and you're speaking
now to what's
on my mind, which is that
dynamic between the East
European who's swallowed
up in a larger Germany
and that matter of displacement,
internal displacement, that I
think is a part of that
history of yours and his.
I mean, even the things that
the refugees go through,
sitting in offices for
hours, or the wasted time.
And I myself lived in a
post-communist country
in those days for
a long time and was
a psychotherapist there.
And there were
such vestiges, even
after the change of regime,
of the earlier regime.
So if there is
just more that you
want to say about that dynamic
between the East European story
and the immigration story,
I would be interested.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] I think
that the problem was
that there were many good people
in the GDR, in East Germany
and that were hoping,
in the first moments
of the so-called
peaceful revolution
and so on, that
they even started
this peaceful revolution
in order to have a way
of founding a GDR where the
right people are in the right
places to get rid of the old
and old fashioned and rigid
government and to have their
own new system in a better way.
The problem was that
there was no time.
The West said, OK,
we will accept you.
Sorry.
Now the medication--
Is wearing off.
--is stopping.
[SPEAKING GERMAN] and then
there was the reunification
of two countries of which one
had 40 years of a completely
different history.
And until now, the
problem is not solved.
I'm sorry.
I think we have to--
Perhaps, I'm sorry.
And I know you have
a question, too.
I apologize.
Thank you, Jenny, very much.
Would you like a lozenge?
A little bit.